crashing very funny show very
beautifully done show thank you I'm
crashing you you're you're playing
yourself or I'm guessing just a real
close version to yourself it pretty much
is you yeah that's a little bit surreal
reenacting things that I actually went
through because the show is about
starting out in comedy there been a lot
of shows about stand-up comedy and
stand-up comics but this is about like
what you have to do along the way you
like anybody who gets starred in this
business there are low points there are
points that you went through yeah before
you had made it of course which you've
used some of that in the show but talk
about that for second points when you
were this is before you've made it
you're probably hanging out with other
comics yeah who who didn't make it or
haven't made it at that time well we
actually it's funny you have to be the
right amount of delusional when you're
starting out in any like weird dream
sorta have to lie to yourself right you
have to do pretty badly on stage and we
like and we would do things this is true
I remember like we would play different
games to keep morale up like I remember
I was on tour that was me Reggie Watts
on the show and Amy Schumer we were
backstage this is 10-15 years ago and to
make ourselves happier because show
business can be so unforgiving and so
difficult we made up a game called I got
it do you want to play I got it of
course sure I knew you would yeah it'd
be a bummer if I said no the show yeah
yeah I got it goes like this you're
gonna be I'm gonna be the person that
went out for some sort of part some sort
of audition okay then I'm gonna come in
and you're gonna ask me how it went okay
and I'm gonna act like it didn't go well
and then a moment of my choosing I'm
gonna reveal that I got it and then
everybody's gonna go nuts okay including
you guys okay it's more fun than it
sounds okay all right
I really hope so here we go I'm even
gonna I'm gonna enter okay and we're
just young struggling comics that are in
the business young struggling comics I
was out for a part it doesn't matter
what it was all right you guys be ready
I got to be Amy Schumer yeah you'll be
any joke
just so you know okay okay yeah here we
go what's up yeah how did it
I don't had the how'd the audition go I
just you know when you think you went
for it I mean he went out for did you
did you say the lines we've rehearsed it
yeah I said the lines
well you're so right for the part I know
I went in I was confident you told me to
be sure sure I knew the lines you helped
me learn the line I did all these
eyeballs were on me there's all this
pressure my heart was beating out of my
chest and I I
here's the only problem here's the only
problem did my butt show nope
the only problem is that most other
comics that age wouldn't have been happy
for you you should do it yeah it feels
really good I'm telling you I just did
it I am elated what's that I feel
fantastic
if somebody from the audience can do it
does someone wanna do you want to do it
he's got a Marlboro Man jacket he's
gonna need a mic Oh laughs Andy I'm sure
they can boom them wait you've got the
doors over there what's your name sir
Farhan nice to see you
Farhan are you Mike right there yeah
hold on to that here go Farhan you
walked into the room we know you've got
the partners you're holding a microphone
yeah well he's a stand-up comedian yeah
that's right Ferran you just meet Nick
oh you tell us that you're you're really
sad and then you trick us and then at
the great moment you tell us okay milk
it Farhan really make us feel sad and
when you think it's time wait another
five seconds yeah no backstage yeah how
do you think he went for farm I don't
know Ferran seemed pretty nervous then
you wear that jacket that Marlboro Man
jacket I told him not to wear it he
looks like a cowboy
here he comes ricotta hey great hand hey
how's it going have a seat man what's
good what's going on Farhan I just went
out for it you know yeah the big part it
was big did you remember to hold the
microphone closer to your mouth did you
yeah yeah just like you told that's a
little too close for Han yeah and how
did any in you did you say your lines
yes I said I said the lines I said them
how I thought I was supposed to say oh
there's a lot of yeah you're perfect for
the part yeah you really had it down
yeah I think it'd make a great Wendy's
girl I don't know what happened
that's what they thought - I got it
great thank you for free from furnace
walnut he's from walnut did it feel
amazing for hon it felt fantastic yeah
there you go
[Applause]